I guess I got to the point where it was
it was really kind of life or death
Selena Gomez and her bestie Francie
Ariza speak out for the first time since
their kidney transplant I should get
overwhelmed by the love that you guys
give me I hope that you guys can just
give the same love to so many other
people too
the singer teared up we're calling her
friends generous donation that saved her
life I just don't really hope that we
can help but I really do I don't I don't
think well we went care was easy
the pop star underwent the surgery over
the summer as a result of her battle
with lupus a source tells ET Selena and
Francia had always planned to speak
about the experience but wanted to wait
until they had healed both stars are
healthy and doing good after the
procedure our source adds my family and
friends I'm just a really happy place
it's been good
well we've learned the transplant was
invasive leaving Francia with a huge
scar across her abdomen but our source
says the grown --is-- actress has no
regrets about her choice to give a piece
of herself to Selena quote Francia never
second-guessed her decision I hope that
this inspires people you're going to
know the third is really good people in
the world
twenty-nine-year-old Francia has made it
her mission to encourage others to
become organ donors according to our
source and I love
and then mean any situation you're in if
you're with the right group of people
that's all that matters
[Music]